[Musique]
vous parlez beaucoup de vous à la vous
parlez de nicolas sarkozy de
personnalités publiques mais de votre
maman aussi vous parler de beaucoup de
vous de votre mariage de votre épouse un
mélissa theuriau une consoeur vous aviez
envie de dévoiler vous l'avez toujours
un peu fait mais de dévoiler votre vie
parce que d'après vous elle est un peu
emblématique
vous comprenez français david j'ai dit
que je répondrai à aucune question j'ai
commencé mon 20 heures c'est par ces
bâtons 20h06 était de 20 ans c'est pour
ça que je vous ai jamais fait à 20
heures je prenais un café ou un café
dans le coin de l'élu à café parce qu'on
est restés là bas de l attendait mais je
vous amène cup
j'ai prévu moi je savais que vous y
alliez assister à vos questions prenez
un café
aucun présentateur du jt d'après un café
dans le terreau profitez-en c'est sympa
en fait vous avez envie que je prenne un
peu de repos exactement
et j'ai un café pour vous aussi
exactement j'ai tout prévu david ne vous
inquiétez pas on comprend un café tous
les deux comment servent à la famille
david ça va pas mal mais c'est à vous
que j'ai envie de vous plus que de poser
la question mais je vous ai dit que je
ne rendrai pas ça le problème
d'accord alors qu'est ce que vous avez
envie de dire ben je sais pas du tout
vous comment vous allez est ce que à
force de présenter des mauvaises
nouvelles toujours des mauvaises
nouvelles
vous rentrez pas chez vous un peu et un
punch et sa des ports gares dès ce soir
il y avait la victoire des handballeurs
français et l'a fait sur les champs
elysées bon vous regarder le jt vous
trouvé qu'à trop de mauvaises nouvelles
chez mon sentiment c'est vrai et ça me
fait mal au coeur pour vous je me dis
que le pauvre ça doit atteindre un
moment mais j'y mets quand même vous
êtes toujours toujours là toujours
souriant et toujours avenant
j'essaye j'essaye mais c'est pour ça
qu'on vous invite aussi pour mettre un
peu de gaieté
est ce que j'essaye de faire depuis tout
à l'heure et pour boire un petit café
exactement comment il est il est plus
facile
et voilà dans le train genres dits
services publics à à boire des cafés
pendant le batteur tiab et je peux vous
poser quand même une question non
vous êtes producteur vous êtes acteur
vous allez être bientôt réalisateur quel
est le métier que vous préférez voir des
cafés disons que j'adore j'adore mon
métier dans son ensemble j'adore venir
au 20h à voir le avoir le privilège de
prendre un petit café avec vous j'adore
monter sur scène j'adore j'adore ce que
j'adore ma vie bon bah c'était un
plaisir djamel de vous accueillir et de
boire un café avec vous on n'en saura
pas beaucoup plus sur votre état
d'esprit à la veille de ce spectacle je
suis très heureux j'espère vous viendrez
je viendrai avec plaisir
on saura pas si vous avez le trac pas
l'air trop stressé l'un si si évidemment
ce qu'il faut de stress pour eux pour
enfiler le moteur qu'il faut vous avez
quand même réussi à répondre aux
questions mais voilà c'est un métier
c'est un métier ça fait plaisir c'est
vrai il n'est pas là pour rien merci
jamel debbouze et on vous souhaite bon
courage et beaucoup de plaisir pour ce
spectacle à paris d'abord en région
après je peux passer une dédicace
si vous voulez jeter de gaza marque oki
à la santé tient bon voilà c'est fait
[Musique]